hello my name is mark greenberg I'm a
teacher from Phoenix and my presentation
is called chicken scratch wolfram for
the homeroom and it's gonna be about a
game that I have devised that uses the
Wolfram language to spawn millions of
trivia questions academic trivia
questions hi thank you for coming I'm
mark Greenberg and I'm here to talk
about chicken scratch but let me give
you a little bit of background first I
may as my wife likes to call it a
semi-retired English and math teacher in
the high school level juniors and
seniors mostly and that's what the game
was designed for but I'm also a an
amateur programmer and that's basically
why I'm here at the conference because
I've got experience programming now I
learned early on in my programming that
programming computers is a good way to
solve practical problems for instance we
had a wrestling tournament that we were
hosting at our school and it completely
fell apart because nobody knew how to
keep score wrestling tournaments are
very difficult to keep score at so by
the next year I had designed a a program
to keep score at the wrestling
tournament so that's sort of experience
in solving practical problems led me to
solving the biggest problem that I had
as a teacher and if any of you are
teachers here you know what I'm talking
about that is engaging the student
getting the student you know we think
that our subject matter is interesting
but the students don't necessarily
especially in high school where as
compulsory so trying to get them hooked
in and engaged in the subject matter is
the biggest problem that I had as a as a
teacher well my one of my solutions to
that was to turn what I was teaching
into games
not entirely I mean you can't teach
Beowulf
as a game you know you can't teach a lot
of the things as a game but some things
you can so when I could I would turn it
into a game into a computer game because
of my programming background and so over
the years starting in about 1998 or so I
made many different games over a hundred
titles and then I left teaching and
became a curriculum developer for a
private company and they had me making
games as well made over a hundred games
for them and then when I left them
I was semi-retired and started making
more games and I've got about a hundred
titles up on the internet now the all of
the games that I've programmed by the
way not all of those are in the Wolfram
language I just got turned on to the
Wolfram language about two years ago so
all of the games most of the games that
I've made have been one player game
they're all educational one player games
and free response so the student would
get some kind of stimulus from the
computer and they would have to respond
back to the computer in some way but the
most the most popular game chicken
scratch is a two-player game and it's
not free response it's multiple choice
so when you see this and you think wow
that's kind of simple because it's
multiple choice
that's not my usual design but that is
what chicken scratch how a chicken
scratch is made now I'm going to show
you some example questions from chicken
scratch Oh
the original chicken scratch way back
around 2000 1999 around then I had about
300 questions in it it's a trivia type
question our trivia type game and the
questions were static in other words I
wrote the question and that question
stayed this
no matter how many times you played and
it was such a popular game that the kids
were lining up before school during
lunch and after school to play the game
anytime that I wasn't actually teaching
a class the kids were coming to my
classroom to play so to to fix that up I
looked at the Wolfram language and saw
an opportunity the Wolfram language has
the ability to for me to write a
template question that will spawn
thousands in some case millions of
questions from that one template so if I
have enough templates no matter how many
times a student plays they'll never see
the same question so the kid that came
in every day at lunch won't become an
expert unless he's really good at the
academic questions you know he's not
going to memorize the questions so I
know a lot of talking nothing to look at
except for the fractal on the screen so
I'll go ahead and advance through the
slides okay this first one is an example
these are all going to be examples at
the beginning of questions in chicken
scratch and so you can see that it asks
a question it gives you four possible
answers and in many cases it gives you a
graphic and I because Wolfram is so good
at creating graphics fairly easily I
want to make the best use of that so
you'll see graphics and many other
questions and in this one you can see
it's a a geolocation geo map type
question I always read the question the
map shows the moves from birth blue to
death red of which of these famous
people anybody have an answer for that
I'm sorry Mark Anthony is correct yeah
and so kids might not know who these
people are but they might recognize nice
the name mark Anthony is somebody that
is related to Julius Caesar or Cleopatra
and realize that hey that map is showing
only areas that are in the Roman Empire
so they might not know the answer per se
but they're able to piece it together
and that's the key really to all of the
questions in chicken-scratch is that
they offer an opportunity to take what
you know in the world
and kind of used Gestalt methods if you
will to come up with an answer rather
than specifically knowing the answer
what else did I want to say about this
slide I think that's it oh there's a low
level of variability in this particular
question because what I have I built a
mini database from the Wolfram curated
data I've taken my own subset of that
and it's only got about 25 different
famous people and the database also says
where have they moved throughout their
lives and so this is a this is generated
real time the map is from that data okay
so let's go ahead and take a look at the
next one okay so this one is another
example this is taken from the stock
data
I think it's called stock data and in
Wolfram Alpha or in Wolfram language and
for this one you know let me think a
second okay this one's more variable
than the last question and the lot
because in this one I've got about a
hundred and eleven companies that I've
pulled out from the larger set that
Wolfram house companies of the students
would recognize or very large companies
that they wouldn't recognize and so a
hundred and eleven of those and the way
I wrote the template the the game will
ask one of 14 different questions from
for that company okay so it may ask what
is the on what day was the highest
volume on what day was the lowest open
on what day was the highest close what
day was the greatest this one says the
best performance you know not only that
but this is real-time data so it's
actually taking the last five why I made
this slide a couple weeks ago but
whenever you're playing it's going to
take the last five
trading days and form the question from
that so every time a student sees or a
player sees this question it's going to
be different because it's taking a
different five trading days for the
question boy time really does fly when
you're up here okay all right the next
example on this one a larger a larger
variability in this question because
it's randomly generating the function
and it's randomly choosing from random
rail the two x-values that go in there
so what's the approximate value of this
now I want to I want to show you clever
students that understand algebra very
well will realize they don't have to
calculate anything here I haven't given
them actually enough information you
notice that the function rule is not up
there for them to do any calculations
and they only get maybe 30 seconds 45
seconds or so to answer and then they
have to give an answer so on this one
they might realize that F of 2.5 is
going to be over here
and that whole side of the function is
negative F of negative 1.7 sorry is
going to be over on the left on the
left-hand side which is all positive or
almost all positive so they might
realize that a negative times a positive
is going to be a negative number so no
calculation needed if they're clever and
they understand the algebra pretty well
they can jump to an answer and that's
the case in many of the questions and
since they're randomly generated
sometimes that'll be more obvious than
others for students okay this one's kind
of neat I think I actually took the
astronomical formula for the Doppler
effect and had it plugged in some random
variables and had it formulate the the
visual and so on this one like I said I
read the questions and I read the
questions for a specific educational
reason and that is I know how the
educational language is supposed to
sound in context so by the players
hearing me read many different contexts
and using the academic language for
instance the word indicates or the word
observed object that kind of layers
their understanding of the academic
language the vocabulary so in this one
the Doppler shift of the observed object
indicates that it is moving you know on
anybody have a guess on this one okay it
is moving towards us you're right so you
just eliminated half of the answers yeah
it's hard to get it's hard to go from
there right the right answer is the top
answer because it's quite a far blue
shift on that one so if a student has
seen blue shifts before they might
recognize that it's not it's a larger
blue shift than usual okay so the last
example and if everything works right
I'll show you a live example of this
this is where I use the the wolfram
graphics I think to to their fullest at
least to the fullest that I'm able to do
and in this one the habitats range for
which of these aquatic species is shown
in the blue chart or in the in blue in
the chart and you can see that one of
the bars is blue and it's basically
asking which one of those animals is the
blue one well now that's a 3d graphic so
I can rotate that I can't do it here
because this is a static slide but I
knew that that was going to happen so
I've got it primed up hopefully to know
what happened here okay maybe please
work yes
okay there we go this is a live question
in chicken-scratch same question just a
different a different random variation
of that question like I said they're
templates and it gets filled in randomly
so same question the habits have range
for which of these aquatic animals and
the the question is asking about the
Atlantic butterfish the glass eye
the grasp Porgy or Porgy I'm not sure or
a fish called the Tusk and notice that I
can rotate that this way and they can
see where the animals live as far as the
depth this is 500 meters so one of these
the one we're looking for is in very
shallow water only all the other ones
are in fairly deep water and one of
them's in looks like deep ocean water
lives in deep ocean water and if I
rotate it this way you can tell what
latitudes they live in oh that's not
good
okay that's really bad okay so the whole
I just got the blue screen of death is
what happened on the laptop yeah it's
not the projector it's the laptop okay
it's coming back up now okay so what I
was hoping to do and looks like my
timings about right if the computer
comes up okay
it just went totally totally blue here
and totally black on the screen yeah
so let's see and I'm not sure where they
stored my files okay I see it okay okay
so while I'm doing this let's see if I
can do this and talk at the same time in
the talkable
okay I could try that yeah that is gonna
be easier because this folder seems to
have a bunch of talk files we'll wait I
think I've got it
chicken scratch and CDF okay what I
wanted to do I was going quickly because
I wanted to play a little bit of chicken
scratch with you because you don't get
the feel for it unless you play because
there's a competitive aspect to it and
are you seeing this you are that's good
let's get it fullscreen okay yeah it
looks like I've got about two or three
minutes to play so why don't we divide
the the audience up right here this side
will be team one and this side will be
team two okay just so you get an idea
we'll only play a couple of questions
normally we pay to play to 300 guests to
$300 first is the winner so it is
pointing to team number two
so what category would you like
anybody from team nur literature okay I
heard literature so I'm gonna pick
literature there's 15 categories in the
game only nine of them show at any time
so that if somebody's really good at one
of the categories they don't run the
board okay and the writings of JRR
tolkien which of these characters is a
man of bear Theo bear Theo okay who
would
okay Ellen dill give it a try okay what
just happened this shouldn't be loading
anything when I click the answer it
should have played a sound Oh and it
didn't even play the sound okay that's
that's what you hope doesn't happen when
you're speaking but that's okay so that
was the wrong answer anybody from this
side want to give it a try
which answer would you like to pick okay
yeah now that question and it's loading
again I don't know why it doesn't the
100 times I practiced before this it
didn't do that okay so that was correct
let's let's just do maybe one more
question or or two ok so it's this
team's team number one what category
would you like to pick geography alright
okay now it does have to go out to the
cloud and come back and that might be
why it is showing loading on the bottom
and moving a little bit more slowly than
when I play it in the classroom normally
it's a very smooth game there we go
which region of France is shown in red
on this map anybody from team number one
can answer yeah I think you guys are in
trouble because if they get it there's
somebody over there that knows what do
you think
okay he's saying the second one second
one was not correct okay I'm not going
to try to pronounce that thank you
okay so so that's the way the game works
and you can see I mean the audience was
was pretty pretty sedate until we
started playing right and now we've got
smiles and interest that's what happens
in the classroom too so that's chicken
scratch now I am uploading chicken
scratch all the files there's a lot of
files that make the game work because
there's a lot of cloud objects that is
pulling from to make the to make the
questions I'm making those available on
github I'm saying making because I
didn't get them all uploaded before we
before the conference started so I'll
get them all up there and you are
welcome to download them and I'll put
some instructions in there too about how
to you know configure it so that it'll
work on your system it works
it's totally Mathematica so if you've
got Mathematica you can make this work
what else I do have on talkable five of
the files so that you can open it up and
look at it it calls out to some web
objects the web objects return for
different pieces of data returns the
question either as a string or a string
form it returns the the answer as a as
an integer one through four because
there's only four choices it returns
four strings which are not always
strings sometimes they're images or
something but for objects that are the
choices and then an optional graphic and
the graphic can be either an image as
you've seen some or a real wolfram
graphic okay now I know I went through
this quickly and I'm going to take
questions five minutes worth
questions or two minutes worth of
questions I'm sorry okay okay so I have
to leave right after this
so I'm gonna get I'm gonna hand out my
card to anybody that wants to contact me
and learn more maybe get it you know
there's actually a playable version on
Tocqueville too so what questions you
have yes
yes
I found the learning curve for for
Wolfram to be steep at the beginning
because I think I wasn't used to
functional programming that threw me a
little bit and then once I got the idea
that I could rap you know do the usual
just two brackets and the name of the
function and then put just about
anything I want inside of that then it
started a flow more easily and now it's
it's pretty easy especially since I can
go back to the if-then statements if I
can't figure out how to do it the
Wolfram way any other questions
no okay
thank you
[Applause]